well I'll just say before this person
please go 74 degrees but we're working
on it Thanks all right yes please take
advantage of coffee if you need so it's
actually it's great to go right after
Andrea because she's done all the
motivation for me and I can jump into
some more detail so this is a lot of fun
so I'm a Georgia Tech and there i'm a
excuses works i'm a director of the
robot autonomy interactive learning lab
and what our lab works on primarily is
this interaction between users and
robots in particular more about learning
kind of the whole goal of this or one of
the goals of this workshop is to discuss
this topic right and so there's a lot of
work that happens on the bottom here in
this robot learning component right we
haven't we have seen a lot of talk in
that and my lab is done working the
space trajectory based learning and task
learning and combination of high level
learning a lot of learning which is kind
of an interesting interface to be it but
what we spend a lot of our time thinking
about is actually not just this bottom
block the learning box itself but these
arrows there's interactions in this
fluid space between the user and the
robot there's a lot of really
interesting questions I think to ask at
that space how do we provide how do we
users provide demonstrations to robots
the mechanism by which we convey that
information and it turns out the way
that we conveyed that information on the
powers that we give to be user actually
significantly influence the effect and
performance of the learning algorithm
even if you keep learning out there than
the same the inputs really change how
the algorithm performs what example to
either choose to give sewing again this
is kind of nice fall one on andrea's a
discussion of how you know how do you
pick what aspects of the demonstration
to provide which key frames or whatever
else how do we how does the robot
interpret demonstration from now getting
closer to the robot component how does
the robot actually understand not just
the demonstration itself in terms of you
know XYZ coordinates but the intent of
the demonstrator a lot of the time when
we teach we actually have broader
meaning and what we're trying to convey
and then there's kind of the upward
arrow right because this is not a
one-way process from the user to the
robots a lot of people think of it it's
a two-way Road right and so that we have
to also think about what can the robot
do is an active learner what questions
could have asked right similar to how
children when they learn they're very
very active participants when should the
robot interrupt so how does it time
these questions because anytime you ask
a you something almost always it's an
interruption right you're taking some
cycles some brain cycles away from a
human doing is too often it's not a
great idea so when should we time those
questions and how do we correctly phrase
our questions in order to elicit the
connecting member information so these
are really to me really interesting
questions but this kind of in-between
right they're not really part of the
learning box they're not really part of
the alone because they stand both worlds
and so these are the questions I want to
talk about or some of them that I want
to touch on today so I'll talk about
three different things the first is a
serious project I won't i'll just gloss
over some of them but if the series of
projects we've done over the last few
years on remotely controlling robots and
having remote human teachers now explain
why their remote and what kind of
interactions were looking at and this is
part of this downward arrow looking at
how do we get demonstrations from users
as well how do we learn from them next
I'll talk another piece ooh about
downward the downward arrow looking at
symantec reasoning and interpreting
demonstrations correctly some of that
intense and high level reasoning that
I'd like to pull in to this learning
problem and the final one is part of
this return arrow from the robot to the
user and I'll just talk about a recent
project we've had on figuring out the
timing of asking questions and interrupt
ability of users and whether we can
learn
predict when we should interrupt
different people so I'll start with the
first one our web based remote
interaction work that we've done for a
number of years and it's a very simple
picture that captures the project we
have a robot here's pictured as a peer
to which is throwout we started with
we've now moved on to several new
platforms since then but we want to make
the throw bot be accessible to users who
are not graduate students just within I
university because those are not the
typical population we're interested
we're interested in working with users
who do not necessarily have robotics
experience maybe or not as technical as
computer science majors who typically
come to our user studies and so what we
want to do is make the trouble out
online of course when we were doing this
you know crowdsourcing is huge as well
so there's a whole population we'd like
to tap in to get more data because I
left d robot learning from demonstration
typically starved for data right it's
very expensive to get to have people
come in and give demonstrations both in
terms of multi because of time right and
the main expenses is time and so we
wanted to make a robot available through
the web in order to collect data more
easily and of course we're not going to
have people install complex robot
control software and their desktop every
kind I want to use it so what we did is
developed entirely an interface entirely
in the browser which I'll show you
examples of in a second and so now we
have a framework that enables anyone
across the world to just open up a
browser go to a particular website and
have whatever level of control we allow
them over the robot so that interface is
actually with the nav stack so for
navigation interfaces with the
manipulation perceptual components and
so on so we can we can decide how much
control to give them this is these are
all open source efforts that support
this and there's robot web tools which
actually does the brow all the files of
plugins in particular it's been a big
collaboration with Chad Jenkins who
moved from brown to Michigan recently
and back when Willow Garage was around
they were in a night and so on but it's
still alive it's still I'll show you
kind of the recent interfaces from that
so this is the framework this is the
idea right so a I'm not going to talk
about how did the kind of
as an ounce of the system aspects of how
we got this working but I want to show
you some of the effects on what we can
do with it very quickly I guess before I
go there I'll say that it's grown beyond
our lab this is from a recent I Ross
paper showing robot web tools running up
five different devices and the fact that
it's now in the browser allows you to
interface with users using lots of
different devices across the world and a
list of NASA's picked up on it a little
bit and had some of their robots in it
as well just another fun but here's an
example of one of the first studies we
did this was this is actually the second
study we did using this kind of
interface and I like to show it because
it gives you an example of an interface
right off the bat so this is a browser
screen and this is what the user sees
they can be anywhere else that could be
here at Berkeley right and our robot is
somewhere else and this is what we see
in the last these are not synced up but
this is basically what we see our robot
standing there moving its arms moving
its head doing stuff and the users are
controlling the robot and they get a
camera view the robot actually has about
seven different cameras so they can
switch between all of those there's a
risk camera and so on so they can get
different views of whatever they're
doing we also have 3d models that can be
helpful and what they're doing here is
picking objects up this was a simple
study you can see this it disappeared
for a second but this is called an
interactive marker it's a six degree of
freedom ring an arrow marker model that
allows you to position right the end
effector the gripper in different
locations and what users are doing is
picking up different object we've
structured this is a game of the
gamified study we found that ended up
really helping for a variety of reasons
so we're giving people points when
having the pic objects up as many
objects as they can in a fixed amount of
time and the reason we're making them
having them do this which for them is a
game it's kind of fun because they get
to play with a very cool interesting
robot is on our end we're learning 3d
object models and graph models at the
same time so given just this right we
get
perception data from the robot the robot
has both a Kinect camera and a panning
laser scanning laser here that allows it
to build 3d models with the objects as
he's on the ground or not in the ground
on the table in front of it and each
time somebody picks up an object the
robot remembers what that object looks
like and we're on that 3d model the
gripper was located at the time of the
pickup so that's that's very simple so
each example gives us one partial view
right object from this way this way this
way this way and if we take all those
examples when we do an iterative point
cloud registration process right we can
build a full 3d model given enough
sample to convert a full 3d model of
that object onto which we then can map
the grasp locations where the gripper
was the users are completely oblivious
to this process right they are playing a
game we're getting this nice data and
the nice thing about it is these models
can now be mapped to so if you see an
object in the world right you can
compare it to the models you've seen
before and that provides object
recognition in 3d but more importantly
it provides a place for you to figure
out where to put the gripper if you
wanted to so it was a simple way to to
perform this object recognition and
grafting process now a lot of the data
that comes from the crowd is is noisy
right and all crowdsourcing and
including with robotics and even despite
our best efforts sometimes throw it
thinks that pick something up and it
didn't and you can see if you watch that
one ended but if you watch any of the
videos I can restart you can see this
failed grass right and so some of the
models they sort of do the grass were
not pro prima and so what we do after
some number of examples from a human
then the robot goes on its own and try
some of these graphs out ranks the
resulting graph and in the end when it's
done following this training process we
get very close to a hundred percent
performance in picking up a variety of
objects yeah yes don't worry about the
fact that do users might take front of
different
trajectories in accomplishing the same
task and then if you end up imitating it
you don't get exactly the one call
exactly the other and middle ground is
not so good that's a really important
question the question was if people give
different than very badly different
demonstrations that accomplish the same
goal with different ways averaging them
doesn't necessarily make sense now in
this case we're getting around that
problem by only remembering the grass
location so as the engine area showed
the actual trajectory is actually is not
very good and we're denying it here
we're retrieving only the end point and
when we have to generate ourselves with
the robot we just rely on planning okay
so we plan through that rejection we
throw it out here but you're completely
right next to me that's a really
interesting research problem that a lot
of algorithms ignoring this community
because in our way in the way humans
behave we have different ways we just
have different preferences and so
there's been a few attempts of
clustering and a few attempts with other
stuff to be smarter but it certainly
there's an awareness we shouldn't just
average in this case we're just planning
ok so the night the outcome of the study
was kind of this this kind of result
that we had comparing a robotics
graduate student in training the object
recognition algorithm for set of object
and random crowd users and so my
graduate student is in red and he does
really well but the blue the user study
participants are sometimes better
sometimes which was statistically
indistinguishable from him and this is
really one of the few studies in the
field where we get a result that says
okay you know a trained grad student he
does this all the time performance
roughly slows is a random crowd of
people and it's partially because of the
way it's been designed because this
refinement process that we go through
but it's also shows that if we just have
access to more data right even if
someone does noisy we can filter it out
the whole benefit of crowdsourcing does
filter down to the robotics world as
well there's some outliers on this this
was an object not picked up a vision
ever this was a Africa a negative
aspects of gamification we had a little
toy truck with wheels and if he failed
to pick it up it would sort of you know
it was hard because if the robot bumped
it it would roll away and so people
because they were playing for points
they just didn't didn't demonstrate this
one they they're like okay any of the
other objects are a lot easier they're
not going to move and so this one and
didn't end up working in the user study
because we didn't provide enough data so
that's something we would we would
redesign or give more points for this
one next time if we're to do it again
but in any case this was a promising
kind of early stage study and then we
went on we had to school so this is a
different robot this week at jacobs
you've seen at several of the other
talks and we have the school creating a
really complex domain moving from
picking place too much more complex
actions and we would get the crowd to
show the robot how to do all kinds of
complicated things open all kinds of
puzzle boxes containers all kinds of
things we would record all that and
learn from it because we even had this
kind of mock idea of what we would be
like and we had a major roadblock and
the major roadblock was that that ring a
narrow marker that I showed you that
looked like this for controlling the
gripper requires you to specify the
gripper location of six degrees from
that and this is the most standard
interface used most widely in robotics
so DARPA Robotics Challenge teams used
it it's the standard thing that comes
with Ross but as far as getting naive
users inexperienced users who are get
not graduate students with yourself
first time using a robot getting them to
do complex tasks like solving various
articulated object puzzles or interested
to move things or even to just put
precision grasp something ended up
taking way too long and we and having
significant number of user errors of
missed graft and then
and we couldn't actually do any of the
learning because what we were recording
was just users frustration and they did
not want to stick with it very long so
we had to back up and we had to look at
better ways of getting data from users
in this remote setting and this goes not
only for LSD not only learning from
demonstration but for all robot control
right how do we remotely control robots
more effectively for something other
than just picking up an object and
putting it down which is which I think
where most of robotics is focused so far
and we've got we've made some good
progress there but we want really more
precise craft so here's an intermediate
set of objects these are not the hard
ones we originally planned but there's
some thoughts and challenges here okay
you've got to grasp a particular handle
on these plastic drawers this isn't it
is a little box designed for
preschoolers it has a very small lip
made for little three-year-old fingers
to open and slide the box to open make
it open we have a cup full of pens we
need to extract a single 10 from we have
things we want to pour out or and screw
and so on and so we said okay let's
what's working to intermediate problem
can we design interfaces that work here
before we go to more complicated domains
and so we conducted a study comparing
sweden's and interfaces and so there's
kind of two contributions that we have
here first two interfaces that we are
now added as well as the study itself so
this is the traditional ring a narrow
market that I showed you before right
now this is our baseline and again it
has six different things you can control
right three four position or three for
orientation all right and so to pick up
in the object and I'll show you video of
it in action you it again so this is
this is our base one that worked
appearing against the next one is
something called we call constraints
positioning it comes from a CAD
community so we went out and we looked
at how other communities outside
robotics deal with this problem in the
cad community this is known as
individuate which we thought was an
unusual name so we want too much
constraint positioning and the way it
works is you click on the object that
you want to pick up and then the rest of
your interactions for the rest of
corrections do grippers constrained to
work on a sphere bounded to the center
at that object and so now you've reduced
you've constrained your problem right
you've reduced some of the degrees of
freedom and all the user is now
controlling if the end of the approach
angle by moving along the surface of the
sphere as well as the how far off the
gripper is and its rotation or its
orientation so that's kind of
intermediate you go from six to three
controllable degrees of freedom and the
final interface is something we call
point-and-click because that's literally
all you have to do you click on the
object and the robot autonomously
recommends some grasp it tries to infer
what you meant in terms of interacting
with the subject and you just get to
pick the graph now the way the flat one
works real quick going to have to
don't have that control in this screen
but this is building off something
called antipodal grasp identification
and learning that comes out of
northeastern out of robbed last group so
here's a visualization of it given that
little wooden box i showed you for
preschoolers if you click on it the
algorithm analyzes the surface normals
around the places where you clicked it
analyzes its surface geometry of the
object in 3d space right so you click in
2d the youth are only sees us in 2d but
the algorithm has a 3d scene from the
Kinect analyzes surface normals it's
hard to see where the lip is here but
the algorithm can figure it out and it's
so it recommend that predicts that has a
classifier that predicts where the best
locations are to place the gripper in
order to prefer to performance called
antipodal grass bracelet that would
pinch from two sides and make contact
with the object and so what Rob price
group has produced a method that's
called agile to calculate these graphs
we've kind of extended it in our work
and made it interactive so having said
that let me show you a study that we ran
with 45 people recently comparing these
three algorithms and this is the web
browser interface that they saw again
this is remote users they're using a
browser baited based interface and
what's going to change between study
conditions is this middle section of
what they're seeing and then these are
the controls for once they have the
grasp they can pull and push objects in
different ways but this is the first
exist or interface this is free
positioning and it's going to show you
in all three cases opening the drawer
right and this is it so this is the ring
and arrow what it takes to carefully
position to open the door now this is
the only interface where we're giving
users also 3d data because we feel it's
advantageous to be able to do this in 3d
so it's a little bit more expensive to
stream it you'll see the honored other
interfaces are actually easier to look
at as well because they're just too d
and so here you can see most of the time
is spent refining
this last bit which is actually
important is how to align carefully and
your field of view is kind of limited
your depth perception soon the user is
going to be happy with it and when
they're happy to go okay move on go
ahead and and so then the arm plans
autonomously to that grass location that
make sense and so now the gripper is
closed this is just showing overlay
showing you what happened and then they
say move back and the arm is going to
open the drawer so that's what it takes
to do one graph okay this is why we
couldn't do harder actions here's the
other interface this is the new pitcher
this is the constraint positioning it
click once you get a sphere you click
the second time it places a grip around
on the outside of that sphere you can
then tweak that virtual gripper position
it but it's constrained it's always
going to come towards the place that you
originally clicked and so that element
of depth perception that you're
otherwise missing is going to be
automatically taken care of by the
algorithm because even though you're
clicking on 2d data i guess i should
mention that the algorithm feeds up 3d
data right because it understands how
far how far away that objective and so
you just saw I didn't even get to finish
talking and the door was already open
right and then finally point-and-click
it's going to take a little longer in
this video because we're going to take
the time to show you all the Pandits
craft but in reality is very very fast
so you click you get a grasp and they're
ranked by their most likely best
performance source performance is
usually the first graph that's actually
the best and then you go ahead and say
going you get to open something so this
has been fun this has been a really fun
project because we went from something
that was very very frustrating to use
the sixth degree of freedom have the
standard in the field up to now to
something that was actually much more
usable and much more user-friendly and
when we ran the user study it was really
nice to see a performance between these
algorithms but the more work people have
to do right the more degrees of freedom
they have to specify
the greater the number of interactions
of per task right and this is every
single click that they have to do
there's like over 100 clicks now some
people just like clicking right they
tweak the camera lots of times and so on
but it takes more work for them and the
number of tasks being completed in the
fixed amount of time that we give them
goes up as the interfaces get faster to
use and if the air goes down yeah
they're they're not entirely so as long
as you have 3d data they're relatively
hardware independent because you're just
specifying a point right and so from
them you need to see the planner where
we think it's going to need maybe some
blending is if you have an object that's
really not being picked up well by 3d
vision like very shiny objects for
example you will not get very far with
point and click if the surface of that
is reflective so there you're going to
have to fall back on pre positioning and
just rely on the human entirely so if
you fail each the 3d sensor fails you do
need that fall back but anytime it is
working it looks like it's much better
to go ahead and rely on it
and just to show where the all these
improvements are coming for this is the
number of errors per tax per task so we
haven't are using a for tax total so
number varies per task that are
happening to these users and when
they're doing free positioning which is
in blue you know this is really number
and most of these errors are coming from
mrs. so they're just missing they're
trying to grab something they're missing
okay so this is so this is kind of where
we are now this workers can be presented
next month at HR I and we're just
finishing up a follow-on study just to
kind of to study these interfaces in
more detail but once you can do this
week we can now very comfortably dudes a
table like this we can now our plan is
to move to harder objects or more
objects at the very least and start
looking at actually learning from the
demonstrations we can now finally get
from our users now speaking of those
demonstrations if we go back to this
kind of big idea all these
demonstrations are current objects right
we're largely in this space looking at
people manipulating different objects
not so much the trajectories that we've
seen before because especially over the
web or even in other applications the
trajectory itself is hard to get it
might be too noisy both because it's on
the web but also in kinesthetic teaching
is Andrea showed and so what we want to
do is start to think about objects
themselves is there something more we
can get from objects than just the you
know color properties or so it can we
think about objects at a higher level
and so for this I'm going to back up and
talk about work that's not in robotics
first and then I'll jump forward to how
this connects the robotics this was work
we're first in an analogical reasoning
if you remember those standardized tests
in high school so you had to take that
were multiple choice chair is to table
as you know something into something
those are analogical reasoning questions
I think the test your ability to capture
and understand analogy and a few years
ago we were interested in studying these
and what we did was we took pairs of
words fed them into something called
concepts net which is an MIT database of
common sense knowledge and try to parse
this gigantic graph it has millions of
edges or sub graphs of that large large
graph know to understand the
relationships between words and their
goal of that particular project was not
just to be able to answer this kind of
question so here's an example analogy
question customers to society as
hypothesis is to evidence or etc etc so
you should try to figure out what the
right answer is so the goals that our
project was nothing just understand what
the answer is which has been done before
by the way the answer is d but to more
importantly generate an explanation and
this is kind of the next step for an AI
right this is an automatically generated
sentence that says this is the right
answer because society is based on
customs and a game is based on rules and
now this level of understanding is
important not just so that we can make
random connections that we can start to
get to the next level of reasoning as to
why this similarity relationship holds
so this was that we had a lot of fun
with this project answering all kinds of
multiple choice questions to say T
questions and so on and when we finished
we felt well this is a cool system they
can do all this but who cares about
answer multiple choice questions what's
the practical application and we went
back to the to this diagram and said
well this whole framework really feeds
on words and in this case pairs of words
but we could take away these words so
you could take away the analogy
questions and put in something else and
in this case we said okay but for
robotics there's a whole set of planning
domains for example hierarchical pass
out there planning formalisms where the
players are in regular english right
there's actually a lot of recent work on
reading recipes online or like the wiki
how websites and being able to turn
those into robot tasks those are human
readable they contain words what if we
take those words
and we analyze them when we think about
relationships what can we do with that
and it led us to a project on object
substitution where we try to understand
the given some task how we could fix it
if something was missing thank you if
this works here's a quick demo of the
final one of the final videos from that
so here we have a robot and it's going
to have it pass but it knows about it's
not learning the task itself it says
okay good pack mine school bags needs a
notebook so it's carefully going to pick
up thus notebook put it away and
everything's going to go for great until
we're tell it to pick up something it
doesn't have so the next task is to find
glue and what the robot is going to do
here yes go ahead and so it recommended
to a substitution here and the
substitution this is several steps i'm
skipping here with this understanding
what glue is understanding the sense of
the word glue because a lot of our words
in english has multiple sensors to
understand the context of being used in
this in this task and what other
candidate objects could be used instead
once the user said yeah you don't have
to ask the user we just do it as part of
the demo here and then we also show you
what happens when it asked about
inaccurate thing few seconds so it got
some glue or it's got some tape Nexus to
get pencil can't find any pencils no
that's not
did you cement its head yes go ahead
without grounding this information
that's a exists from this database that
we get off of my out of MIT you get
things like quill which in theory is a
correct implement but in practice is not
going to be found in most houses and
that CC we could filter that based on
the robots vision we could learn user
preferences as well so for example here
we are going to have a user preference
no I don't like banana it should fit
sure go ahead so here this is a
different kind of error where the
substitution that we were trying to make
was just not like you know the user
doesn't prefer it so he rages right Joe
alright so here we have a quick example
of how analogical reasoning which is
exactly in the same variant we used
before to solve multiple choice analogy
questions can now be used in this very
very different context to substitute
objects in similar situations this also
this project was also a lot of fun and
we kind of ended up building on it and
liking the semantic reasoning aspects
that are created but we also want to
expand it a little bit beyond just
similarity of object only we ended up
starting this project over sort of a
fresh looking more broadly instead of
just pulling words from plans also
pulling them from vision using a larger
set of databases not just continent but
also word in that shape net we might
potentially grow beyond those two those
three these are the ones we're using in
the foreseeable future and then taking
given all this data to create something
we're calling in a situated affordance
network which combines the type of
high-level abstract knowledge like a
quill is a writing implement right with
grounded situated information that says
well yes but I don't have quills but I
you know this user likes to use pens or
high-level information
Shin its best says well in general
people keep spatulas and drawers and you
know the specific environmental
information that says this user likes to
keep spatula in a giant metal cup on the
counter right and so this is this
project where it's Blythe what it's
grown into in this case is an attempt to
recreate something we as humans do
really well which is the balance are
situated local observations and our
habits in their understanding of a local
environment with this abstract knowledge
that we're also aware of in terms of
general so if i come to your house and i
need to find a spoon i'm probably going
to start opening drawers in the kitchen
but i'm not going to go open drawers in
the bathroom nor am i going to open the
cabinets in the kitchen right there
certain priors that i have four
locations of objects they serve cars and
have for what containers are and how to
use them and that's where we're going
with this so this is a very early stage
work I don't really have a lot of
results in this case we also do object
disambiguation here or worse sense
disambiguation we switch to a more
probabilistically driven model with
Beijing logic networks the logic
first-order logic components adding some
the transitive properties we need for
our evidence that it's giving us a
little bit more different kind of
flexibility than we had by just
leveraging concept net we get good
inference so far and kind of simple
types of queries we get roughly eighty
five percent accuracy and a lot of
queries just without using citrate
information so far and no kind of the
where we're pushing right now is to
incorporate this low level observations
that we get from the robot camera up
into that model in order to do that
actual blending so we don't have results
on that yet but this is work we're
currently applying and once we have this
information what we want to do is
actually look at in the context of
learning for example if the human
demonstrates something to do with cups
or containers or drawers right how do we
not just take them literally and say
this is a trajectory I've learned just
for this one object how do we generalize
how would you use our understand
well this is a type of container this is
a type of fruit that goes with other
fruit or this thing is made of metal
just like these other objects how do we
learn use that information in the
context of learning and so the other one
last thing I want to say about this is
that some of this information I
mentioned a lot of it comes from
perception some misinformation is going
to come from human so I having to ask
human questions and that brings me to
the final project I want to briefly talk
about which feels with this upward arrow
of having the robot initiator or take
actions or ask questions of the user and
the this particular project deals with
interrupt ability and the timing of
those questions and so there's been a
lot of work in many community is on you
know gesture recognition activity
recognition and so on in this case we're
looking at models of interrupt ability
recognition where we define interrupt
ability is basically the inverse of
workload how interruptible are you this
is something we take so much for granted
as humans right if I see you standing
the hallway talking on your phone even
if you make eye contact with me I'm not
going to just come up and start talking
to you that's not socially acceptable
right and for those of us with little
kids like this is something that they
don't quite understand until a little
bit older and you have to have on the
phone right now but over time with
enough examples humans become incredibly
good at this and we want to look at
making giving that same power to robots
and it's been a little bit of work in
the community before looking at how we
can take a few person descriptors like
pose gaze direction of swords to get at
the idea of something similar to
interrupt ability or workload a lot of
it happens with instrumented humans when
they are wearing accelerometers or
something else and in this work what
we're doing is leveraging again I'm
trying to have this deep interest in
objects and belief that objects carry a
lot of semantic information and the fact
that you're holding a cell phone to your
ear
he does mean something right in terms of
understanding your interrupt ability so
this is the first work we're aware of
where we've expanded not only if we
defined more concretely some of these
interrupt ability measures but also
added this idea of objects and their
importance in providing context for that
interrupt ability so very briefly
interrupt ability to be rated on a scale
for is very interruptive alike go ahead
and talk to this person one is don't
talk to this person they should not be
interrupted zero is we don't know we see
a person man we don't know if they're
interrupted and so this is a sort of
like a Likert scale then we're going to
be mapping onto so far we've done it in
a variety of these settings we're doing
a free-form study next month to look at
it in more complex interactions with
people engaging a broader variety of
tasks but here's a a bunch of images
that i would like to label each of these
people with their interrupt ability
right and they're purposefully picked in
the same environment because even within
the same environment you know this guy
is talking on the phone this one for
Candis laptop this one's drinking coffee
this one's chatting they all look very
very similar right it's but in many ways
we look at not just at their location
but some of the other social cues to
pick up on their interrupt ability and
we want to give the robot the same
ability on so we did was we took a robot
has a Kinect and a laser we coded up a
whole bunch of features that we can
detect autonomously from the robot the
position of the robot of the human their
face Direction gaze direction whether
they're talking whether there's audio
coming from their vicinity things like
that and what we've ended up training we
tested a number of models but uh we had
really nice performance with a latent
dynamic CRF so traditionally the
workings computer community has looked
at hmmm but we we did some we looked a
lot at the gesture recognition community
because there's some an analogous
problem in that space as well and so
this this model for
dynamic CRF ended up representing this
problem particularly well because it
models the both the extrinsic dynamics
between the different interrupt ability
levels is when's the the intrinsic
hiddenly of hidden variables that are
captured within this model that help to
achieve that our performance
particularly as some of these extended
features so we tried different sets of
features just to see how it impacts
performance especially because some of
these other ones are particularly noisy
and the model from the simpler models
like hmm struggle when we add some of
these more noisy features but really
quickly so we compared hmm CRF hidden
serif and League dynamic CRF of which
league dynamics really really dominating
here is a a confusion matrix of
interrupt ability resulting from the LD
serif vulnerable we can see from manaphy
are very very good at classifying mostly
trapped ability levels it's relatively
difficult to figure out what level three
means which is pretty interrupt but
we're not quite sure we that gets
confused with both ways as with a2 and
a4 so you tend to kind of have an air so
people people that are very very clearly
not interrupted we really understand
that okay as as as we kind of get
towards the more and more interrupted
that algorithm has a little bit more
publish it with the ground truth against
the ground truth no I didn't mention it
so how are you doing so the track truth
in this case comes from labelers who are
not us not authors on the paper or
related adults this project coming in
and labeling what they think on the
scale of one to four how interruptible
each of the people in the images and so
we did this with several labelers and
then compared that instead of
correlation test of how much an
agreement they are and it turns out that
they are extremely very very well
aligned and in there
an agreement so what we found is that
human this data collection is staged and
then the next one that we're running
next month is not staged yes but what we
found is like human labelers on this
data are very much an agreement on the
level of interrupt ability which we want
sure it would would be the case because
it's kind of a you could view it as a
varying opinions on what interrupt
ability because mean from a social
setting so this is data this is data
without by the way using any of the
objects I said we are one of the things
you want to try with adding objects for
context and so here is data when we add
objects to black the black shapes are
different amounts of data training data
without objects in gray which i guess is
harder to see here but it's always hire
is are the results when we add objects
into the mix as the features and it's
not not perfect object recognition is of
roughly ten percent error rate in the
object recognition but even so it adds
significantly to our ability to estimate
someone's interrupt ability and so
here's an example of the results on
those images so we see this person
working on a laptop even though we see
their face they've interrupt ability one
these folks who are basically looking
straight at the robot having two are
very interrupted all they look like
they're ready to engage this one on the
cell phone has been trucked to lille 1
interrupt abilities 0 for this person
that we see but we got we their back is
to the robot we don't actually know what
their status and so and so forth so we
get generally what right now if we were
to use this directly to influence the
robot behavior what we would get in
situations like this if the robot would
address the person facing the robot
straight off and be aware of the other
two people would their back to the robot
but not attempt to talk to them as if
there was somebody else present who was
looking directly at the robot which is
the correct social dynamic kind of took
to play into so this has been
interesting
where cuz I said we're going to extend
it into unconstrained on kind of
uncontrolled more uncontrolled settings
to test fit more in the wild but the way
it fits into this bigger pictures I said
so coming kind of coming back and tying
all the pieces together we have a lot of
different questions in a lot of
different projects addressing different
aspects of learning that I've talked
about this last one was about when to
ask when to interrupt people with
questions that robots have about
learning something or asking for help
about something we have projects on how
to elicit that information in different
ways I talked about how people can
demonstrate right we have different ways
of interpreting their demonstrations on
information their demonstrations and so
on right now these are all destroyed
project and I think that's
characteristic not only of our lab tom
but of the robotics field in general
that we tend to have these projects be
niche projects that look at different
sub subfields is sub problems
independently and our hope in the near
future is to start connecting some of
these up right so that these
demonstrations combined with the
semantic knowledge about objects can
influence learning that the robot that's
learning can now start to figure out
when to interrupt different people to
ask for help and so on so we'd like to
see more crossover between these which
is kind of where our lab is heading in
the future and here's a quick list of
all the students have been contributing
to this work students and postdocs and
thank you for listening and I'm happy to
take any questions
[Applause]
very HIV that provides I get a basis for
generalizing highly specific actions
yeah true Apple may be produced from
oranges which I think that so that's one
of the things we'd like to be able to do
with it is to generalize something that
was demonstrating a specific object to
other classes of objects of whether they
belong whether the class is oriented
along the property lines that these are
other metal objects or this is another
another fruit or you know category or
whatever else so that's one thing that
I'd like to do the other is that in a
lot of cases this is closer to what we
saw with the video of the robot packing
a school bag robots end up with policies
that work but as soon as the environment
changes they something changes in that
policy just doesn't apply anymore and
that typically happens when objects are
missing now if you're cooking something
you know you're supposed to mix
something or you know you're missing a
spoon you're just going to grab some
other thing like a fork or even a knife
to make something real quick in order to
add the ingredients humans are amazing
and improvising in this way we don't
just stop and say okay I'm not going to
have dinner because I can't stir my
pasta with a howl without a spoon but
that's currently where we are with
robotics is that if there is no you know
if there's no way to perform this policy
there's really very little adaptation
that happens and so the other end that
we'd like to look at this from it's from
the adaptation perspective how do we
repair plans how to repair policies in
order to allow for greater
generalization so it's along the same
lines of still generalization right and
but instead of from a single
demonstration looking at how to repair
as well
so so that's the foot so the question is
did the objects have to be annotated
with different features and that's
exactly the thing we're trying to avoid
actually so nothing so far has required
hand coding on our part we can detect
certain properties from vision we can
even have tacked on for me we're working
on a project with tactile sensor detects
whether something's metal or wood or
plastic we can do that but the you know
we can also ask humans but we don't want
to get into the habit of just hard
coding all this information for every
single object we want and so that's
where all these resources like shape net
and confident wordnet come in because a
lot of that information has been encoded
for other communities other than
robotics computer vision and so on and
we're trying to pull data in from them
and leverage it there because then even
if you encounter something new that no
nobody's ever hard-coded you have at
least something to go on it's tends to
be noisy data it comes to be incomplete
and overly general I would say right so
we get information that for a single cup
our network tells us it's probably
ceramic and metal and plastic and wood
like it's not all those things at the
same time but it still it gives us a
prior and then we can refine that prior
and based on our observation so but
we're trying very hard and so far
succeeding not to have to hard-code any
of the features for a given object
that's very important so two things so
one it seems like you know right now the
interrupt ability is a binary task you
know do I approach purse match why it is
like you know I mean maybe just
something more than I didn't see but it
seems like you know some tasks that you
want to gauge how much to the user right
so the training task itself is
you know see you could ask them to do
during the whole task or if they're like
on the Sun you could ask them do very
small task you know the same way that we
gave our responses you know how
available is this person for labor or
training right one question the second
has to be with this idea of kind of
implicit features I mean is there any
animal use kind of ambient human
substitution patterns right so like the
likelihood that it so for example my
kids watch you know those craft shows
and my cooking show well like constantly
in these shows essentially engaging in
substitution activities right and so
rather than which isn't just a lot of
passive data I'm not here that's uncoded
boat which is actually yeah you know
because the ideas like are you know how
what are the vectors along which people
are making relevant comparables
conditional on context it's something
for which it's actually potentially
enormous amount of I think that would be
as I'll answer the questions in reverse
order I think that would be really
interesting to learn from observations
for when you count ambient kind of
evidence right watch youth could have
the robot go watch youtube videos they
can it go watch cooking shows can it
watch people in its environment and
obtain information that I think the goal
is yet it's not we have a partnership
with a vision group that's going to look
a little bit into that space but it's so
much of a perception problem more than
you know that if you if it becomes like
core perception right so but ultimately
yeah as we get better at having robust
observed from a distance that's
information that they need to glean I
think that's an excellent way to get
more data right now robots really need
to be a little bit too much in your face
to observe you right so the passive is
kind of in your personal space a little
bit because of the range of 3d sensors
and so on to answer your other question
on the interrupt ability I did presented
entirely the binary problems due to
interrupt or not but the scale actually
we're not thinking that it's entirely
inform it's the only thing that's
informing that binary decision
and that doesn't even have to be a
binary to say I think there's a lot more
beyond this interrupt ability scale that
we're providing like how urgent is the
robots task right the building is on
fire but you're not very interrupted
because here on the phone I'll just let
you burn right that's not that's not
really a valid right and so we had
there's a lot a lot of other factors
that need to be considered but and then
we could also extend it to not being
kiss binary but smaller interruptions
have less cost than larger interruptions
I mean it could get much more
complicated I think this is just the
precursor that says based on vision let
me just get your state I know my state
okay the next question is what do we do
from that data
great thank you
[Applause]